after more than 30 years the
rehabilitation of the marcus name in the
philippines is nearly complete
bongbong marcus jr the only son and
namesake of the country's late dictator
is now its next president after winning
an unprecedented 31 million votes
the marcuses are considered one of the
most infamous political families in asia
and their name has long been synonymous
with decadence and abuse of power
they ruled the philippines from 1965
until 1986 when they were ousted through
a people power revolution
the president of the republic of the
philippines
his inauguration on thursday is
noticeably more grand than those of his
predecessors aquino and duterte there is
more parade and pomp than usual but his
speech focused less on nostalgia and
more on reconciliation
we will build back better by doing
things in the light of the experiences
that we have had
both good and bad
it doesn't matter
no looking back in anger or nostalgia
in the road ahead the immediate months
will be rough
but i will walk that road with you
the marcus resurgence is the result of a
decades-long well-funded campaign to
revise history in this year's election
online propaganda coupled with the
marcus family's vast wealth and their
alliance with duterte paved the way for
his presidency
but his administration is expected to
face a tough road ahead the country is
facing its worst economic crisis in
decades its education and public health
systems are in shambles and society is
deeply polarized
across the capital several activists
have been arrested by police an all too
familiar scene during his father's
regime
but historians say although the past has
a way of catching up with the present
the conscious future under marcus jr has
yet to be written and so there is little
choice but to give it a chance to unfold
jamal allendogen al jazeera manila